عندما برز اسمه معركه سوليدار سلطت
الاضواء على نجاحات قوه فاجنر الروسيه
الخاصه تلك المجموعه الاكثر سريه في
العالم كما نعرف راويه والتي تتضارب
الانباء عنها وعن ماهيتها بين تصريحات
روسيه وتقارير غربيه نتعرف عليها اكثر معك
نبدا
من هذه قد يكون
بامتياز الموت هو عملنا وهو يسير جيدا
فكلما وجدت صراعا لا تستطيع ان تتدخل فيه
روسيا رسميا عبر جيشها فيمكن حينها سماع
اسم فاجنر التي كان في موسكو اي علاقه
رسميه بها ترددت الانباء عن فاجنر في
سوريا ليبيا ومالي وجنوب افريقيا واخيرا
اوكرانيا فعندما لم يستطع الجيش حسب
المعارك في دوم بس كانت فاجنر الحل
البدايه كانت عند
غينيا
طباخ بوتين الذي هذا كان لقمه الذي اطلق
عليه لان بدايته كانت كصاحب مطعم ومتعهد
طعام ثم اسس الشركه واصبح حتى تتخذ الان
مركزا رئيسا في مدينه سان بطرسبرج وتعتمد
بشكل الرئيسي على تجنيد قدام المحاربين
الذين يحتاجون الى سداد الديون وتغطيه
التكاليف الحياه وكسب المال فيما تتحدث
التقارير الغربيه عن مقاتليها ومعظمهم كان
عليهم احكام السجل مجله نيوزفيك نشرت
تقريرا استعانت فيه بخبراء عسكريين
ومراقبين كشفت فيه ان يفقين بيغوجين يحاول
استغلال معركه فوليدار لتعزيز ثم عدفاغنر
كقوه قتاليه قادره على الحاسب بعض اخر
اظهره التقرير ان بيجو يحاول تعزيز خزائنه
ومواصله اعماله عبر تمويل المقاتلين
المرتزقهم بس المراقبون اكدوا ان طبخه
بوتن يريد ان يثبت كفاءه مقاتله وسط
المنافسه المتعثره للجيش الروسي في
اوكرانيا وعدم جاهزيه الجنود الروس بالنظر
الى نتائج عام على القتال في اوكرانيا نجد
ان حرب الشوارع كانت الطاغيه على الصراع
والتي فشل فيها الجيش الروسي بامتياز فيما
نجحت فيه فاجنر حتى الان اذن المعايير
الاخلاقيه قد تكون معدومه لديهم فهم
يقاتلون من اجل المال اما ان يقتلوا او
يقتلوا مهما كانت الوسيله وصور الدمار
الهائل التي نراها في سوليدار دليل واضح
على ذلك
[موسيقى]